ま、いわゆる促力人材イコールすぐ稼いで
もらいたい人材って意味じゃん。側力人材
から始まったんだよ。ただ僕はやっぱり
理想は高かったよね。パーパス目的を貫い
てきたから目的を共有できる人間が残り
目的が違う人間は去った。青木サの人生
警額100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、人材育成を行う体力がない会社で、ま、中途採用でスキルのある側占力人材を採用したいと考えることは、ま、どうしてもあると思うんですけれども、え、理念共よりも促力でスキルがある、スキル採用をするお年穴があれば教えていただけますでしょうか?
うん。
あのね、これはね、理論というか、その理想というか、その振り返るといろんなこと言えるんだけど、本音はもう精一杯やってきた。
[笑い]
正直。それがもう本音です。
もうそれしかなかった。だから僕はもう毎日が真剣勝負でその時最善と思うことを一生懸命やってきただけなんだよ。
で、その中で結果的にパーパス、目的経営
を貫いてきたから目的を共有できる人間が
残り、目的が違う人間は去った。ま、結果
的に今いい系ができてると僕は思ってます
。38年経営して最初から理念共官型採用
できたわけじゃないもんね、ぶっちゃけ。
最初は社員5名、資本金500万で
マスタートしたわけだけれども、最初の5
名っていうのはちょっと縁があった人って
ことだよね。やっぱりそういう人しか集め
られなかったし、逆にそれでも一緒に働い
てくれたことに感謝してるよ。だって
マンションオフィスだから組織としては何
の魅力もないでしょ。高い給料出せないん
だから。それで、ま、能力開発の
プログラムを売る、研修を売る。昔は
アチューメントって創業当時変な
セミナー会社、変な自己啓発セミナー会社
みたいに思われた時代もあるわけだから。
だからま、本当恋の炊きのりじゃない
けれども、ゴルフで言うならアゲンスト、
もうマイホールアゲンストみたいなもんだ
よね。それもすっごい恐風が吹いてきてさ
、打つとわーっと天ぷらするみたいな。
それぐらいの風の中で着実に打ちながら
低い玉打って、低い玉打って最後はもう
ゴロで行ってそれでも前進してね。いや、
本当にそうやって生き延びてきたのが実態
ですよ。だから即戦力人材から始まったん
だよ。ただ僕はやっぱり理想は高かったよ
ね。ま、そんなマンションオフィス
スタートした時からキーワードは日本一な
のよ。
桃太郎だよ。日本一のキ団子だよ。
やっぱり2識の見旗っていうか。でもそれ
は僕の個人としてやっぱりトップ
セールスマン、トップマネージャー、
チーフトレーナー、ま、トップ
コンサルタント
っていうもう若い時から1番を目指してき
たそういうピークパフォーマーとしての
考え方って僕の実は会社のコアだと思うん
ですよ。ま、これが専門的な言葉で言うと
コンピテンシモデル、ま、いわゆる理想の
人物像みたいな理想というものを常に僕は
描きながらお客様に喜んでもらいたいと
いうその気持ちは全く変わらずにそこから
一生懸命仕事をしてきましたよね。ま、
そんな高い能力のある人、支出の高い人
集めれたわけじゃないので、当然のこと
ながら最初ブラック企業みたいになるわけ
よ。ま、長時間労働ですよ。本当に申し訳
ないと思います。当時の人には。でも即線
力じゃないと会社が潰れてるでしょ。ただ
ね、いいですか?これ大事なテーマなの?
僕は育成力があったんですよ。だから営業
にさる人間が確信を持てる商品を与えられ
、やる気の出る環境で仕事をすることが
でき、やる気のある人材を次々と採用する
ことができ、採用した人間を1人前に
育て上げる
仕組みがあった。それは私が元々独立する
前にトップセル、トップマネージャー、
トップコンサルタントだから僕の中に技術
があったってことだよね。だからそういう
側力人材を入れても毎日ともかく話し込ん
でこういう会社にしたい。こういうことを
大事にしよう。もっとお客様に喜んで
もらおうよと。どうしたらお客様に喜んで
もらえると。そうすると例えば農業開発の
プログラムの売りっぱなしじゃなくて
フォローを徹底的にすることによって顧客
満足を上げる。でもそれは儲けから来てる
んじゃないのよ。利益市場主義じゃないん
ですよ。だから1番最初に僕がやった研修
はね、美容室の研修でした。まるまる1日
ね、行って5万円いただいたかな。
ありがたかったね。で、火曜日、美容室
って火曜日が休みだから火曜日研修やって
、で、その後どうでした?研修効果はって
言ったら、いや、青木さん研修すごく
良かったけれども効果っていう意味では、
ま、1回研修やっただけではそんな効果
ってすぐは出ないよねって言われて、
じゃあよかったらフォローの研修させて
くださいとか言って、で、また火曜日に
フォローの研修をほぼ無償でやって、そし
たらすごくその経営者喜んでくれって紹介
んですよ。でもこれが僕のビジネスのひ方
だと思うの。つまりそうやってフォロー型
の社員だけれども僕が戦闘切ってなん
だろう価値を想像してその価値を一緒に
フォローしながら社員がそのお客様の
フォローしながら紹介をもらいながら特別
な能力がなくてもその促線力というのが私
の大事にしてることをちゃんと一緒に共有
してくれる人間が少しず増えて10人、
15人、20人ってだんだん増えていって
、ちょうど社員が26人ぐらいの時にね、
2004年からいよいよ1人の4大卒子を
採用して、その子はすごく能力高かった
ですよ。で、その子に大学生向けの採用の
仕組みを考えてくれと。僕大学行ってない
から本人に考えてもらって。で、そっから
本人もうちに務めながら大学院行っていい
よって言って、うちながら大学院通って、
で、彼がその仕組み、採用の仕組みを考え
てくれて、ま、そっから2004年から
あの新卒採用始めたんだよね。それまでは
もう新卒採用できる力がうちはなかったと
思います。で、社員26人の時に16人
採用したね。翌年2006年また、え、
16人。でも実際のところうん。
アチューメントは要するに即戦力人材新卒
でも即戦力人材採用したために彼らは勉強
で一時的にここで何か起業する参考になる
ものがあるのかなとかやっぱりその即線力
人材だからこの組織型じゃないんだよね。
で結果的に多くの新卒の子たちは離職して
いきました。で、色々学んでいく中で
やっぱり目的人数でもなくやっぱり目的
から採用というものをしなきゃいけないと
。だから、ま、今はもう本当にね、そして
新卒の240人のうち80%
ぐらいかな新卒
率になってると思います。でも今
アチメントは本当におかげ様で、え、理念
共官型採用うまくいってるんだけれども、
ま、グレイトプレストtoトゥワークでも
ね、グランプリ取れたりでもやっぱり即戦
力だけ集めていたとしたら多分ブレイト
プレストワークでは絶対グランプリは取れ
なかったし、離職はいつも多い職場だった
ような気がする。やっぱり目的本当にお客
様の喜びを我が喜びとするという価値観の
人が残り組織の一員として長期的、本質的
客観的に見て共にこう成長していけるそう
いう人材が今の会社の文化を作ってくれ
てると思う。
だから、ま、今回のテーマでね、言うと側占力人材、側戦占力人材っていうとそういう文化になっちゃうので、
そうするとなんかこう部合だとか報酬とかお金っていうところがなんかこう散らついてくるし、やっぱり利益は目的な結果であると利益や理準を追求する系ではなく、お客様に喜んでもらうんだということを追求するとやっぱり長期的、本質、客観的な視
に立った採用しなきゃいけなくなると長期
的本客観的に見たらいい経なというのが私
の結論ですね。即戦力、速線力って言うと
事業証計もできなくなっちゃうしこれ
落とし穴ですよ。あとやっぱいい人材が
離職する可能性あるよね。
いい人材って文化をすごく大事にするので、いい文化の中でいい人材がやっぱり育っていくので、だ、文化がちょっとやっぱりざらつくよね。
うん。だ、いい文化を作っていくとはそういうことをね、大事にした方がいいんじゃないかなという風に思いますよ。
うん。
ま、すごいなんか今の質問と直接違うね、
回答してしまってるようだけれども、ま、
いわゆる側力人材イコールすぐ稼いで
もらいたい人材って意味じゃない。それは
まず経営者自身が育成力を持たなきゃいけ
ないんじゃないかと思うので、規模の拡大
よりもクオリティをやっぱり追求するべき
だと私は思います。時間かかっていいじゃ
ないですか。うん。だからすごくうちも
正直この240人の組織になるのにすごい
時間かけてるわけだよね。だけど最初は
売上100億、経住力20億、社員500
名で1番最初考えたんですよ。でも結果的
に売上は84億かなグループ全体で。
そして経常利益は約30億でも240人
それ成し遂げてるからやっぱり採用に妥協
しなかったからだと思うのよ。で、
やっぱり促力人材ということよりも理念
共官型人材を採用して時間かけて育ててき
たから今の組織になってると思うので、だ
、目先の尊徳を追うとやめられる可能性も
あるだろうし、金の切れ目は縁の切れ目に
なるので、やっぱり何がその絆になってる
のかっていうことをやっぱり経営者は
しっかりと頭の中で整理して経営した方が
いいんじゃないかなという風に思いますね
。ま、ちょっとね、長くなりましたけれど
も、ま、是非ね、私なりの実態権で得てき
たことしか言えないので、ま、参考にして
いただければ幸いです。で、僕は、あの、
たくさん自己啓発書を読み農業開発してき
た人生なんですよ。アメリカにも27回
ぐらい研修受けに行ったり、本当に僕は
自己開発してきました。だから、ま、是非
ね、あの、この今日の内容を読んでいただ
、あの、見ていただいた方はね、拒否を
築づく思考法っていう本リッチ
、こナポレオンヒルの著作物ですけど、私
観約してますので、この虚父を気づく思考
法だけは是非読んでいただきたいという
ことと、経営者は人生理念作りから始め
なさいという私の著書をね、ちょっと読ん
でいただくとこういう考えに至っ
本質的なことが理解していただけるんじゃ
ないかと思うので、最初私は即戦力人材
しか集めれなかったんだけど、でも速戦力
人材を集めようというよりもそういうこと
すらもないね。まず一緒に働いてくれる人
を集めようみたいなそんなところで努力し
て少しずつ軽自分の中にある正解を求めて
努力し続けて今日があるということなので
、ま、参考にしていただければ幸いです。
え、是非ね、ハイプの方でもね、是非新
機能応援してください。あとはコメント欄
にもね、コメントお願いしたいですし、
それから高評価とあとチャンネル登録ね、
しなくても見れるんですけども是非ね、
チャンネル登録で応援していただけると
すごく嬉しいです。また次回の
YouTubeで会いましょう。
ありがとうございます。感謝します。
ありがとうございます。あの、今の青木
社長のお話を聞いていて、やっぱりその、
ま、本当にその当時を振り返って、ま、精
一杯やってこられたっていう風に
おっしゃられていた。
やっぱそのなんて言うんですかね。そのお年穴がある意味あるかもしれない。あるかもしれないって思ったら逆にこうはまる可能性ってあるかもしれないなと思ったんですけどやっぱそのその時その時で最善を尽くすっていうま
うん。
本当にその人材育成に、ま、え、行ってく体力がない会社で、ま、新卒業やりたいけれどもスキル採用になっちゃうっていうところであれば、ま、今おっしゃっていただいたやっぱりその最善を尽くすっていうなんかそこ以外にない道がないのかなっていうのはちょっと感じ。
そう、そうだよね。
だけどさ、これちょっと深い話になっちゃうけど、岡口も早稲田出てアチーメントを選んで、
15年、16
年前のアチーメントって今のアチーメントとは全然違うアチーメントじゃん。
そうですね。
でしょ?
はい。
で、まね、ワンワン世代だから
2011年採用だよね。
当時親の反対とかま、当時
人か同期は
えっと入社の時は23人ました。23
人いたか。ああ、その23
人入った子たちはよくアチューメント当時選んでくれたなと思うんだけど結局僕は全部の採用に対してトップライブとして出ていったし、
1人1
人に対して僕は誠実に向き合い、ちゃんと正直に僕はこういうことを大事にしてるとか、こういう社会を作ってきたいと
は、ま、特にね、不満足な人間関係が禁
するあらゆる不幸をこの世から撲滅したい
んだとかそういう目的に共感した人間が
当時ないづしじゃん。オフィス環境も良く
ないし、ま、長時間労働でもあったしまだ
ね。それこそこな間だ岡口が言ってたけど
新卒あの新人新卒の子がえ口マネージャー
大変ですよ。
もう大変なことなんかアチーメント書かれてますよってね。そしたら口がね、あ、それね、あの書き込みね、昔のアチューメントのことってだ、昔はそんな会社だったんだよって。で、みんなで努力して今良くなってきたよねっていう話だ。新卒の子から見たらあ、今のアチメントしか知らないからこんなこと書き込まれてますよと。
[笑い]
嘘かけられてますよって言うけど、もうそういう時代があったじゃん。だ、そういう意味ではでも僕って変わってないよね。昔も今もね、そうですね。
だから何度も僕は社員にも謝ってきたんですよ、実は。ごめんなって。もっと力つけてみんなを幸せにできる経営者になるからって。ありがとうってついてきてくれてありがとうって。いや、本当に何度もそういうメッセージを全体議でもしたと思うんですよ。
だから僕の中には理想があったのよ。ま、
例え言うなら稼ぎはまだね、良くないけど
ごめんな。絶対いつか必ず豊かな人生を
送らせるからもうちょっと頑張ってく
れって奥さんになんだろう。詫びてる
かっこ悪い定だったけどでもそんな
イメージだけど傲慢ではなかったっていう
の頑張るからってでそれを信じて奥さんも
支い続けてくれたみたいな。だからそれと
よく似てるんだよ。で、今結局そこで代償
払って不完全な中一生懸命残ってきた社員
は自分たちがこの会社をいい会社にし
たっていう誇りを逆に持ってる。だから
愛着もすごい強くなってるしなんだろう。
その出来上がった会社に入った人間とは
違う
なんだろう貴族意識っていうかそういうの
があるんじゃないかと思うんだけどどうか
な周りみたい。
それは俺が言ってもしょうがないことなんだけど、どんな感じ?
いや、でもあの本当にそれはおっしゃっていただいた通りのところがあるなと思いますし、か、最近まで私も周りに気づいてなかったですけど、やっぱりその、ま、うん。
もうこの有明けに移転してきてから当然
見えてる世界とやっぱりそのま、前のま、
高グリーンビル時代[笑い]ある意味こう
知っているあのからこそのこの変化を
やっぱり喜べる気持ちだったりとか今の
アチーブメントに対してももっと上がる
なってもっとよりよくできるなって思える
気持ちはやっぱ来てるのかなとは思います
。そうだね。うん。
やっぱりねんだよ。エ理を無さぼるんじゃ
ないんです。
もっといい技術、もっといいサービス、
圧倒的な価値を想像できる組織体を僕は
作っていきたい。これからさらに良くなり
ます。として誇れる本当の意味で解消持ち
として社員に対していや社長を信じてね、
やっぱりついてきてよかったと言って
もらえるような、ま、いつか僕も人生の膜
閉じる日が来るんだけどその時にやっぱり
社員が本当に社長と出会えてよかったって
言ってもらえるようなね、ま、経営者で
ありたいなと思ってますよ。うん。もっと
頑張ります。